new rule the Washington DC priests who  refused to give communion to a woman  attending her own mother's funeral  because he found out that she was a  lesbian needs to convince me there is a  hell so I can tell him to go to it yes  because shunning a woman at her mother's  funeral that is totally what Jesus would  do  who doesn't recall the biblical tale  where Jesus sees the center and forgives  him sees the [ __ ] and cures him and  then sees the woman with the short hair  and says ooh what are you some kind of a  lesbian why don't you hop in your Subaru  wagon and get the [ __ ] out of here  and don't let the door hit just went  pants on the way out all right